Rachel Lindsay began her search for love
last night and we are joined right now
my former best read Ali Fedotowsky man
oh I love the name you just sat down
with Rachel as long but I liked it
yeah I know it's very long sorry about
that but yes I did get to sit down with
her she's just the best
I mean how wild was that premiere last
night right we saw a whole lot of crazy
as Rachel met her suitors but believe it
or not one of those guys is now
officially her fiance you're very happy
I am very very happy you wearing a ring
no ring the ring okay so it's not like
the Neil Lane sparklers we're gonna see
at the end of the season but yeah I
think that's nice I mean everyone knows
you're engaged I think wear it on your
on your ring finger and then we get to
see the the real bling later on oh yeah
and it is bling oh my god but before we
see the proposal we've got to get
through the rest of the season 31 men
showed up but only twenty three remain
and in between there was a whole lot of
drama so you know I just had to get the
Bachelorette breakdown guy that was
interesting as laboux you give her a
rose I did why did you give him a rose
he was interesting I gave him points for
being different
and wagers tell me your favorite
qualities of these three guys first
Brian confident um bold what about Peter
he walked out of the limo and I said
okay I mean he is very very handsome one
that sit out was Jonathan Oh tickle
monster I was weird
yep it was different but I laughed in
the boldest move of the night 37 year
old chiropractor Brian dared to plant a
big old first night kiss on Rachel and
she didn't throw the book at him
you're gonna kiss the first night what
what changed that no one tried except
for Brian and he tried in the most
passionate way but to get to the real
truth with our favorite attorney
Bachelorette we had to play a little
game called guilty not guilty or blue v
kissing more than one guy during a group
date
for that did you ever cry over a
decision oh my gosh totally guilty sex
from the fantasy suite yeah good girl
good girl
Oh George off camera though no she
didn't oh the thing if she pleads the
fifth I feel like that means she's
probably guilty oh my god why do I know
how soon going in do you kind of get an
idea of who you're gonna choose it'd be
hard um for me honestly it was the very
first night the first night I knew my
top two guys and I zeroed in on him the
whole time but I actually told her as
advice before she went on to film the
show my advice to her was don't do that
try to keep your heart and eyes open to
more than one guy that's probably hard
lots of personnel there's lots of
characters
[Music]